hello and welcome to med simplified i'm
dr umar malik and in this video we will
talk about the best foods that you can
include in your diet
if you have gout if you haven't watched
our videos on joint pain
i'm going to leave the links in the
description box down below so you can
check them out
gout is a very common disease and its
prevalence has been increasing in the
recent years
it is a painful disease affecting one
joint at a time
most commonly the big toe joint pain in
the joints is known as
arthellatria and joint pain or
arthelasia
is as common as a flu and can be caused
by a wide range of reasons
such as bad posture overuse
and misuse of joints like in case of
athletes such as footballers sprinters
and tennis players
it can also develop due to diseases like
osteoarthritis
rheumatoid arthritis many neurological
problems
kidney and liver problems and gout we
have made
separate videos on most of these topics
so you can check out these videos by
clicking the links in the description
box down below
well goud is a type of arthritis an
inflammatory condition of the joints
it affects an estimated 8.3 million
people in the united states alone
people with gout experience sudden and
severe
attacks of pain swelling and
inflammation in the joints
nearly half of the gout cases affect the
big toes
while other cases affect the fingers
wrists
knees and heels gout symptoms or attacks
occur when there is too much uric acid
in the blood
uric acid is actually a waste product
made by the body when it digests certain
foods
when uric acid levels are high it can
accumulate
crystallize and then settle in these
joints
this process triggers swelling
inflammation and intense pain in the
joints
now the question you might ask is how
does our diet
affect gout if you have gout certain
foods may trigger an attack by raising
your uric acid levels
this is because these trigger foods are
commonly high in purines
purines are actually substances found
naturally in certain foods
when your body digests purines it makes
uric acid as a waste product
normally this is not a concern for
healthy people as they efficiently
remove excess uric acid from the body
however people with gout cannot
remove this excess uric acid from the
blood and thus
a high purine diet may lead to
accumulation of uric acid in the joints
which leads to a gout attack research
has shown
that restricting high purine foods and
taking the appropriate medication can
prevent gout attacks
and improve your quality of life foods
that commonly trigger gout attacks
include organ meats red meats seafood
alcohol and beer they contain a moderate
to high amount of humanes
however there is one exception to this
rule research shows that high purine
vegetables do not trigger cow attacks
interestingly fructose and sugary
beverages can increase the risk of gout
and gout attacks
even though they are not purine rich for
instance
a study including over 125 000
participants
found that people who consumed the most
fructose had a 62 percent higher risk of
developing out
so to summarize if you are susceptible
to gout attacks
avoid the main culprits which are high
purine foods
these are foods that contain more than
200 milligrams of purines
per 100 grams you should also avoid high
fructose foods
as they may trigger a count attack here
are
a few major high purine foods and high
fructose foods
that you should avoid all types of meats
which include liver and kidney meats
also
fishes like herring trout mackerel tuna
sardines haddock and more
seafood like scallops crabs and shrimps
sugary beverages especially fruit juices
and sugary sodas
foods with added sugars like honey agave
nectar and high fructose corn syrup
yeasts like nutritional yeasts brewer
yeasts
and other yeast supplements additionally
refined carbs like white breads cakes
and cookies should also be avoided
although they are not high in purines or
fructose they are low in nutrients and
may raise your uric acid levels
now you know what to avoid naturally you
may ask
what foods you should include in your
diet if you have gout
although a girl friendly diet eliminates
many foods
there are still plenty of low purine
foods you can enjoy
foods are considered low purine when
they have less than 100 milligram of
purines per 100 grams
here are some low purine foods that are
generally safe for people with cow
all fruits are generally fine for gout
cherries may even help prevent attacks
of gout by lowering uric acid levels
and reducing inflammation all vegetables
are also fine
including potatoes peas mushrooms
eggplants
and dark green leafy vegetables legumes
are
also good including lentils beans
soybeans and tofu
nuts and seeds are also very good for
people with cow
whole grains like oats brown rice and
barley
all dairy products are safe and low fat
dairy appears to be especially
beneficial for people with cow
eggs are also good beverages like coffee
tea and green tea have no harmful
effects
all herbs and spices are also good
plant-based oils
are also good including canola oil
coconut oil
olive oil and flax oils apart from your
diet there are several lifestyle changes
that can help you
lower your risk of gout and gout attacks
let's look at a few of them
number one is to lose weight if you have
gout
carrying excess weight can increase your
risk of gout attacks
this is because excess weight can make
you more resistant to insulin
leading to insulin resistance in these
cases the body cannot use
insulin properly to remove sugars from
the blood
this not only increases your risk of
diabetes but insulin resistance
also promotes high uric acid levels
research shows that losing weight can
help reduce
insulin resistance and lower uric acid
levels
that said you need to be careful
dietitians strictly advise
against crash dieting that is trying to
lose weight very fast by eating very
little
research shows that rapid weight loss
can increase the risk of gout attacks
because rapid loss of muscle mass keeps
interfering with your uric acid levels
a good place to start is regular
exercise
not only can exercise help you maintain
a healthy weight
but it can also keep uric acid levels
low
one study in 228 men found that those
who ran more than five miles
or eight kilometers daily had a 50 lower
risk of developing gout
number second lifestyle change is to
stay hydrated
staying hydrated can help reduce the
risk of gout attacks
that's because adequate water intake
helps the body to remove
excess uric acid from the blood by
flushing it out in the urine
if you exercise a lot then it's even
more important to stay hydrated
because you may lose a lot of water
through sweat
number three is to limit alcohol intake
alcohol is a common trigger for gout
attacks
if not the most notorious one that's
because when you drink alcohol
the body prioritizes removing alcohol
over removing uric acid
which lets the normally insignificant
uric acid accumulate and form crystals
leading to gout and gout one study
including 724 people
found that drinking wine beer or liquor
increase the risk of gout attacks one to
two beverages per day
increase the risk by 36 percent and two
to four beverages per day
increase the risk by 51 number four
is to try a vitamin c supplement
research shows that vitamin c
supplements can help prevent carb
attacks by lowering uric acid levels
it seems that vitamin c does this by
helping the kidneys
remove more uric acid from the blood and
letting it leave via the urine
well friends with this we come to the
end of this video
if you like our channel and want to
support us consider leaving a like
sharing this video or becoming a member
of our youtube channel
you can also support us via patreon
links are in the description box down
below
we at med simplified are always
committed to bringing you the latest and
updated content
thank you so much for watching and see
you in the next video